you know what's great the fact that
we're getting a Thor 2 this year you
know what's awesome the fact that we
have the first trailer right now so the
first trailer to throw the dark world
came out today which is Thor 2 star trek
into darkness the dark world's gonna be
very dark year for dark movies a very
dark darkness it's called the dark roll
so yeah who thought Legend of Zelda Link
to the Past when they heard that title
raise your hand I know at the beginning
you see this fire truck floating at odhh
who's doing a voiceover is all like in
the beginning people think there was
nothing but that's not true they're
wrong it's not like that guy from Game
of Thrones actually I'm sure most
captains say that while their ships are
still afloat but apparently there's this
big evil coming to earth the next thing
you see Thor comes to Natalie Portman
he's like I told you I'd return although
oh sorry kat dennings it's probably the
last we're gonna save you in this movie
other that's a good thing kat dennings
azad I'm just saying that's probably the
last time we're going to see her in the
movie that's what it looks like really
big things that are really bad are
coming to wipe out the earth it's
official the reaper for mass effect are
coming but now they're actually Dark
Elves in this movie Dark Elves are
coming to wipe out everything it makes
me go that's interesting because any
time I play a fantasy based game and I
get to pick my race I always pick dark
elves which means those are my boys so I
got a pick between my boys and four
let's sacks Arkells totally Thor if Thor
was a dark out let's just make Thor Dark
Elf make my world easy you see that hot
warrior chick from Asgard is probably
like yeah Natalie Portman you got that
you're hitting that I could break you in
half with my pinky and Thor picked you
you thought dudes were competitive
chicks are the worst trying to tell me
she's not thinking man I mean naturally
from the get-go from this trailer I was
interested in it because it's poor too
and I really liked Thor 1 but I was
thinking 2013 it's looking good there is
some stiff movie competition out there
I'm thinking about Star Trek into
darkness right now Iron Man 3 Man of
Steel so I was like what are they gonna
do in this trailer it's gonna make me go
okay now I'm also thinking about Thor 2
and it happened Thor had a conversation
at the end of this trailer you should
know that when you betray me I will kill
you when do we start back you see that
hair his hair gets longer every movie
look at that that is nasty it makes
me want to grow my hair out so I have
one feature on myself that looks or
resembles if you all know this by now
this is no secret
Loki's great I love that dude I got my
Loki hot toys it's actually ordered and
coming to me like oh the bad guy from
the last movie has to team up with the
good guys to take out the greater evil
the timeless tale and I do like it
Thor makes it pretty clear they're not
just here for Earth they're gonna take
out everything darkness is gonna reign
supreme again so it's like wow his
business alright let's not have the
entire universe get destroyed you think
Santos is behind this we saw him at the
very end credits of the Avengers to this
being I'll call it the second wave of
Marvel movies the ones that are leading
up to the Avengers do I can't help but
think somewhere in this movie are gonna
see that Thanos is like oh hey I'm
behind it all so the trailer for Thor
the dark world have you seen it what did
you think about it are you excited for
this movie he's coming out in November
which is you know strange I thought it
was strange at first and I was like oh
that's when Harry Potter movies came out
and they came out and falls oh I guess
it's normal it's like in November
one or two big movies are allowed to
come out then I guess it's yours Thor -
cuz that totally would be a summer movie
whatever you think about this trailer
comment below let me know as always you
feel like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]